tough to come up like for me something
it was something new because back home I
growing up like you know for us
relationships kind of we built in
something together from scratch so you
met your you know a man it doesn't have
probably nothing as you don't and in
together we built together so that's the
way in which I see relationships so I
don't I can obviously pretend from a guy
to you know okay be a billionaire right
do you think girls only care they only
don't care if they can't get the guys
that are rich
they don't care like I feel like girls
only don't care about money if they
can't get the guys that are successful
I've always been like that even you know
all my 20s and I actually was as you
said them you know my best I actually
been for long with in our relationship
or my 20s and I decide to leave the guy
so and that guy wasn't that he was rich
rich no he wasn't oh he wasn't but
that's you want to say I'm sorry I'm
saying like if you have got a guy I
actually didn't date a rich person to
stay with a broken one yeah that's
probably why I did what if you dated a
rich person no I said I add like
honestly speaking at the beginning when
I met my ex-boyfriend I date once a guy
was richer than him
six foot tall
ER oh anyway good looking and I actually
prefer my the one that after became my
boyfriend that wasn't six foot he wasn't
rich I was a footballer you know I mean
I actually pick him as if you ask me why
that's always a reason why don't you
stay uh with the this guy because
growing up I was 25 when I left him I
had different plan from him so I decided
to leave the country to you know develop
my career study it he actually followed
me but at some point for me I just
decided it wasn't the guy yeah but so
it's kind of like you picked him but you
did it you picked him for a little bit
but then you didn't pick him six years
now literally probably is more than some
marriage he was with him for six years
yes
and that's like scarier to guys though
because it's like you stayed with him
for six years and left
I'm just like no I think I just I think
he's caring if a woman is the same women
science I mean from our 20s she's sixth
of signs she get 40. you cannot be the
same person when you're 20 and when
you're 40. if that is the case damn you
know growing up like you cannot be the
same person at 20 and in your 40s so I
think I actually you know I had a
development
and and this could happen that you know
they developed and didn't match my guide
development so you know we just end up
in different do you throw your values
the same when you're 20 and then when
you hit to 40. again wait I think I
already asked this question like I
already answered
uh if I mean from my side evaluate it's
not about the young be pretty and be
virgin the value is about the topics
that you can come out with is about your
knowledge it's about what you can do by
your own uh is about or if you've done
like in those 30 years what have you
done if you study have you work what
have you actually built in your life
what do you have it's like that's like
that's that's man though that's like
what women want for them
yeah no no that's what girls do is they
become the men they want to marry
yeah yeah I'm not yeah I mean a lot of
girls are because feminism feeds women a
lie because I mean the least happy
demographic of women is 45 single and
childless
and and it's like what what does your
career matter if you don't have someone
to share it with like I could be a
multi-billionaire and if I came home to
an empty house my life means nothing
that is like the set like and then it's
like like what you get to focus on
yourself all the time you run into your
big house and hug your dogs and you're
over the moon no because like life is
not about just about I I'm at the
opposite way I'm kind of scared about
those women that they focus every
thinking they marriage and they children
because at the end yeah why because at
the end like at some point you're just a
human being you need to be focused also
on your on yourself that when you have a
family you have some needs no because
when you're when you're a man yeah when
you're when you're a mother it's not
about you anymore it's like your kids
happiness comes first but it's like if
you're it's if you can't put your kids
before yourself like yeah you probably
shouldn't have kids yeah but many people
like I think we are a great I think that
many people actually as they decide to
have
I think girls decide not to have kids
because they can't get a guy that they
want to have kids with
I think because most girls if I talk to
them if they set up if you found a guy
that checked all your boxes would you
have kids with them the answer is
generally yes yeah so to me it's that
they can't acquire the men that they
want and the men that they want don't
want them
you said that already yeah you said that
earlier
I've heard that I've heard that from
women
I've heard that from women and they'd
rather die alone or like just be alone
yeah
when you start talking about oh yeah
when you start talking about being an
independent woman and what you bring to
the table and if he can't match that I'm
fine to be alone what you're saying is
okay
I can't find the man I want so I'm Gonna
Be Alone yes exactly
because I don't see like the need for a
woman right now in 2022 to add other men
next to you like I don't because I'm I'm
not looking for a man who can provide me
financially I don't look for a man who
can protect me so like my man must be my
friend what if he was a bum he could
protect you but he bum like he doesn't
work
you're not looking for him to provide
yeah yeah but no I I made the point very
clear like I want someone that is like I
it must be like my friend it must have
Focus like me like exactly like kind of
me but obviously you know the the yeah
but
like so in a way you do you did become
the man you wanted to marry yeah you you
can actually say that yeah and it's it's
like almost sad to me because I feel
like you actually think like that's what
men want in terms to like a career woman
and they just don't care like would you
date a girl without a job yeah
did you marry a girl without a job yeah
yeah but we thought we coming back to
the same point he's free to do whatever
as I am free to stay by my own yeah
because I'm not sad as you think I go I
go anyway family I got niece and nephews
I got a job and I'm taking actually a
lot of a lot of
um I'm happy I mean you're also you're
also beautiful and so so like but Beauty
runs out at some point and when Beauty
runs out the attention yeah but when
when Beauty runs out the attention stops
because nobody's knocking on your door
at 60. no one's knocking on your door at
50. and like life is lonely after 45 if
you don't have a family I wouldn't at
low my Sunder and I will understand men
who thinks I should just be in the
kitchen washing dishes I'm not saying
you don't be lonely I honestly prefer
being lonely for the rest of my life
then keep myself my ass in the kitchen
washing dishes most men don't care if
you have a job like most
I'm saying most men can't even afford to
have you washing dishes in the kitchen
yeah so most men aren't going to require
that of you but what I'm saying is like
if you don't prioritize family it's
going to be lonely and